cuántos caballeros más hay que princesas
en el castillo veamos aquí tenemos a los
caballeros
y la barra nos indica que la cantidad de
caballeros llega hasta aquí hasta el
número 14 entonces tenemos 14 caballeros
lo escribo acá tenemos 14 caballeros
ahora hay que comparar porque queremos
saber cuántos caballeros más hay que
princesas aquí están las princesas y
está barra nos indica que tenemos cinco
princesas entonces tenemos cinco
princesas
y para saber cuántos caballeros más hay
que princesas hagamos una resta
entonces vamos a restar estas dos
cantidades
14 - 5 eso es igual a 9
entonces tenemos nueve caballeros más
que princesas
y aquí también lo puedes ver si tú
inicias aquí y aquí ves cuántas
princesas más necesitas para tener la
misma cantidad de caballeros entonces
ves que necesitas toda esta cantidad
pero cuánto es esto es 9 necesitarías
sumar 9 princesas y lo puedes ver aquí
si iniciamos aquí tenemos entonces una
dos tres cuatro cinco seis siete ocho y
nueve princesas entonces cuántos
caballeros más hay que princesas en el
castillo la cantidad es 9 hay 9
caballeros más que princesas en el
castillo y terminamos